it's going to be case keenum versus
carson wentz week one as washington
takes on philadelphia because keenum
wins the starting job to start the
season washington coach jay gruden
announced that news on sunday look
bottom line it's just a matter of time
before dwayne haskins plays chris and
they've got some tough defenses they
face right out of the gates so you keep
dwayne haskins protected you let him
continue to get comfortable and you wait
for the right moment to flip the switch
and we talked about this before week
four week five something like that yeah
maybe at the giants maybe at home
against the patriots i don't know that i
want to give him his first start at home
versus on the road i think at giants
would be a game where dolphins get out
every week six there at dolphins week
six right if the patriots come to town
and thump washington that would make
sense the bye week's not until week 10
that's the natural spot to give them two
full weeks to get ready by then though
the season may be lost i look i think
they they feel like they got a better
chance in the short term to win with
keenum and jay gruden needs to win or
he's not gonna be the coach next year
yeah i i think it's hard to you know in
this situation you mentioned the early
schedule that we had there too i mean
the eagles the cowboys the bears okay
those three alone you know it's hard to
sell to your team we're trying to win a
football game with the guy that's you
know oh doesn't know every little detail
of the offense and can't do all the
mechanics at the offensive line you know
that's the team's going to go watch are
we trying to win are we just trying to
you know build one guy's confidence and
career for the future and you're right
jay gruden wants to win football games
and i think ultimately it's the best for
the the washington redskins to start
case keenum it's ultimately the best for
dwayne haskins too who showed us moments
and we go oh wow there's something there
but he is he's still young and raw and i
think needs to polish a few things up
about playing the position you think
they keep colt mccoy on the roster i
don't cole mccoy
the guy that i look at and go you know
there's some interesting like trade bait
or quarterback situations right now in
the nfl where we talked about teams that
don't have good backups and here's team
that has a plethora of quarterbacks
where you know there's some teams that
could call them and go we need this guy
to be on our roster i thought about
picking them when we did the position
group draft last week sure because they
got three good quarterbacks and the
colts just lost a franchise quarterback
the chargers they got three good
quarterbacks we'll be right back
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports